what happened in court today is
precisely what we wanted to happen
the high court certified
that we had raised point of law point of
law of general public importance
and that the supreme court has good
grounds
to hear this appeal
the situation now is that the supreme
court has to decide whether it will hear
the appeal
but make no mistake we won today in
court
[Applause]
but let's not forget that every time we
win
as long as this case isn't dropped
as long as julian isn't freed
julian continues to suffer for almost
three years he's been in belmar's prison
and he is suffering profoundly day after
day week after week year after year
julian has to be freed
and we hope
that this will soon end
but we are far from achieving justice in
this case because julian has been
incarcerated for so long and he should
not have spent a single day in prison
if there had been justice
the officials
who plotted
who conspired to murder julian
would be
in the courtroom right now
if there were justice the crimes that
julian exposed war crimes the killing of
innocent civilians would not be impugned
our fight goes on and we will fight this
until julian is free
there's still to add but
the point that is being raised here in
this court was the absurdity that after
the magistrate court came to a decision
the americans were allowed to bring
forth the so-called assurances that they
would treat julian fairly if and when he
was actually the united states
everybody that has looked into those
so-called assurances
have condemned them and judged them as
not being worth the paper they are
written on
the american government has made such
assurances before and they have broken
those assurances
they actually entail in those assurances
the clause that they can change their
mind at any moment
so it's not worth anything
but as stella says the fight will
continue
and it will not end until julian is
freed from belmore's prison and until
the u.s government drops this case which
is a blatant and serious attack on press
freedom worldwide
but this today was a partial victory
a partial victory
but asella says
the punishment goes on it's a punishment
by process a serious human rights
violation the torture is ongoing in
belmont's prison he has been there for
more than 1 000 days
that is happening here in this country
today that is the newest item of the day
from reporters without borders i would
just like to add again we welcome this
decision this is a positive step it's
not far enough yet but it is a step in
the right direction
this case is historical it will be
hugely precedent setting it will have
implications for journalism and press
freedom in the uk in the us and
internationally for many years to come
it deserves review by the highest court
in this land and so we very much hope
that the supreme court will accept this
appeal
as others have said as well the
situation that julian assange himself is
in is very urgent we have serious
concerns about his well-being at
belmarsh prison the long-standing mental
health issues are well documented we
have concerns about his physical health
as well especially knowing what we know
now about the mini stroke that he
suffered in october and about the
reports of rising covet infections in
the prison again at this time he is not
safe as long as he is there he should be
immediately released whilst this process
is ongoing so from reporters without
borders we will continue to campaign to
free assange we call on the biden
administration again to drop the charges
to close this case once and for all this
legal process does not have to continue
it is in the power of those in the u.s
government to put a stop to this at any
time they can do so and we will continue
to be here and to monitor any further
legal proceedings in this case this by
no means guarantees an appeal for julian
assange today but what it does do is
give him renewed hope that he may apply
to the supreme court for an appeal
against his extradition to the u.s and
it was the same
two judges who made that decision in
december that he uh could be extradited
to the us that uh held this 90-second
hearing today at the high court where
they ruled that they wouldn't be able to
give leave for an appeal themselves but
that julian assange and his supporters
could go on to apply for an appeal to
the supreme court so it does now give
julian assange and his fiancee stella
morris who we just heard from
there one of his most vocal uh
supporters some hope that they could
potentially overturn this
decision now i should say that julian
assange faces 18 charges against him in
the u.s
including breaking
a spying law and he's wanted over an
alleged conspiracy to obtain
and disclose highly classified
information uh from the national defense
uh center following wikileaks
publication of hundreds of thousands
of classified documents
in 2010 now for julian assange's
supporters he's a valiant campaigner of
truth to his critics he's endangered
lives by exposing
highly classified secret
information but for many uh this
extradition
to the us undermines the foundations of
democracy and press freedoms in both
country and it's raised a great deal of
concern here and as stella morris uh
julian assange's fiance highlighted
there he remains in belmarsh prison the
highest security prison here
in the uk
and she's said that juliana sanchez
already served far longer in belmore's
prison than prisoners who have who have
committed violent crimes they
have two very young children together he
uh fathered two young children with
stella morris during his time in the
ecuadorian embassy she says they have no
recollection of their father outside of
a maximum security prison and if he were
to be extradited to to the u.s he could
be sentenced uh to up to 175
years in prison
so
this there's still a long road ahead for
julian assange and his supporters today
but certainly renewed hope that they may
be able to appeal his extradition to
america